what's up everyone it's Warren today
we're going to talk about the cosmic
entities being in Avengers endgame
specifically three of them two of which
have already been mentioned in the MCU
so I'll be talking about them and be
talking about how it seems to line up
perfectly for them to enter Avengers in
game also the Infinity Gauntlet giveaway
winner will be announced at the end of
this video so be sure to stick around to
see if you won and if you're new be sure
to subscribe to my channel for Marvel
and superhero related videos so like I
said there are three cosmic entities
that I want to talk about all of whom
are very connected to the events that
have already happened in the MCU and of
course Avengers infinity war
specifically and how not just one of
them but all three of them could be this
new threat entering into Avengers
endgame if you're not aware of the new
threat or you're skeptical about it let
me explain originally this new threat
came from a toy leaked on the back of
the box of a toy there was a description
that said the word rocket would have to
face against a new threat some people
thought this was fake because the toy
like was fake and therefore the new
threat was fake but it actually doesn't
matter because not too long ago a book
came out called Avengers infinity war
the cosmic quest vol 2 aftermath this
book is canon to the MCU meaning that
everything that has talked about in this
book and that happens in this book
happened in the MCU whether we see it on
screen or not and you don't even have to
read the book to find out that there is
in fact a new foe coming in Avengers in
game you can just read the back cover of
the book and it reads as follows a
deadly threat emerged from the cosmos
and it was fulfilled in the wake of
Thanos is horrifying success the people
of Earth are left reeling and despair
and confusion without any logical
explanation for the blip out event those
remaining must pick up the pieces dr.
Erik Selvig and his associate Darcy
Lewis are determined to find and
understand the cause of the devastation
with a team of friends both old and new
they embark on a pursuit of knowledge
eager to discover the links between
their own pasts and the stones that
decimated half of humanity the Infinity
stones little do they know that a new
foe who threatens to destroy them all is
looming so again this book that is K
to the MCU states that Thanos was
successful in his snap but a new foe is
looming and threatens to destroy them
all so a new foe is coming and it seems
like it could be cosmic entities based
on the way some things are lined up in
the MCU so I mentioned that there were
three let's start with number one
eternity eternity is the actual
embodiment of all that there is in the
universe he is and has control over the
reality of the universe and Fanus just
severely changed and altered the reality
of the universe so eternity probably has
a problem with somebody altering the
universe since he is everything in the
universe now some people think that the
cosmic beans are just too much for
people to handle and they won't
introduce them into the MCU but here's
the thing they've already been
introduced the Celestials are cosmic
entities and they've already been
introduced in guardians of the galaxy
volume one and guardians of the galaxy
volume two in guardians of the galaxy
volume one the guardians go to nowhere
which is actually just the severed head
of a celestial then when the collector
is explaining the Power Stone we
actually see another celestial S on the
searcher and then of course in guardians
of the galaxy volume two star-lord
finally meets his father who is in fact
a celestial and not to mention star-lord
was half celestial as well that is until
he killed his dad and it's very
important to keep in mind that there are
different levels of cosmic entities yes
there are some extremely powerful
Celestials but the ones in the MCU pale
in comparison to Eternity who has
control over the universe and ego
himself actually makes a reference to
this in guardians of the galaxy volume 2
when star-lord says that he's a god
ego replies small gee son I'm what's
called a celestial sweetheart celestial
like a God small geez
this is because there are actual cosmic
entities who control the universe such
as eternity and the two others that I'll
mention in this video and know for a
fact that these cosmic beings do exist
in the MCU we learned this from the book
Thanos Titan consumed which again is
canon to the MCU we learned that the
cosmic entities are out there and
actually watch over the Infinity stones
in this book Thanos asks the lore
speaker why no one has tried to collect
and use the Infinity stones before and
here's what the lore speaker says a
direct quote from the book they are
hidden Thanos and because the Celestials
and others the ones whom the celestial
sphere keep close watch on the stones
from afar so again the Celestials are
very powerful but there are others more
powerful than them who the celestial
sphere and these are cosmic entities who
actually have control over the universe
and watch after the stones again such as
eternity and to others that I will
mention but again this book is canon to
the MCU so they exist in the MCU and
many people believe that ego actually
showed eternity to star-lord if you
notice in this scene star Lords eyes
turn black and he sees stars and planets
and essentially the universe and he
himself says I see it eternity now
eternity is a reference to time or never
ending an infinite time yet star-lord
says that he sees eternity why would he
say that if he saw the universe many
people believe that he said that because
he actually saw the cosmic entity
eternity and this ties directly into the
Infinity Gauntlet saga in the comics
eternity actually goes head-to-head
against Thanos in a fight after the snap
to take back control over reality and
the universe a fight in which eternity
actually loses but before that there's a
very important part that actually ties
in another cosmic entity to possibly
appear in Avengers endgame and that is
the Living Tribunal The Living Tribunal
is pretty much the strongest entity in
the whole entire universe with the one
above all being the only entity stronger
than him the living tribunals purpose
is that it oversees and maintains
balance in all the realities that
constitute the universe and he serves as
a judge to these realities and one of
his main purposes is to actually make
sure that people do not use all of the
Infinity stones so in the Infinity
Gauntlet saga in the comics eternity
holds a cosmic summit the cosmic
entities appear and eternity seeks
judgment against Thanos from the Living
Tribunal eternity says the mad Titan
seeks to unbalance that which is throw
the nature of the universe into maniac
whole entropy this sounds like something
that we could see in Avengers in game
eternity is definitely being threatened
by Thanos using all of the Infinity
stones and wiping out half of the
universe and the Living Tribunal is the
judge of the universe and it is his
responsibility to make sure things like
this do not happen and the Living
Tribunal already exists in the MCU there
is a direct reference to him in Doctor
Strange he is literally mentioned by
name this is a relic some magic is too
powerful to sustain so we in view
objects with it allowing them to take
the strain we cannot this is the staff
of the Living Tribunal so it is
absolutely 100 percent clear that the
Living Tribunal exists in the MCU and
the nature and the balance of the
universe which is the living tribunals
job to uphold the balance is at jeopardy
so it seems very apparent that the
Living Tribunal would have some issues
with Thanos using all of the Infinity
stones to wipe out half of the universe
and the last cosmic entity that we could
see in Avengers in game that is
connected to the events is Chronos
Chronos is a cosmic entity with control
over time and the power cosmic
and he's also Thanos his grandfather in
the comics he creates Drax the destroyer
for the sole purpose of killing Thanos
so he's not exactly his biggest fan but
again he has control over time and
everybody is pretty much expecting
time-travel to be a huge part of
Avengers in game and he also has the
power cosmic which gives him Universal
cosmic awareness so he should be aware
of everything that has happened with
Thanos and the Infinity stones and the
snap if he exists in the MCU and he
should exist in the MCU because again we
have been introduced to cosmic entities
and in Avengers infinity war Red Skull
mentions thanasis father a Lars well
Chronos is the father of a Lars before
Chronos was a cosmic entity he was an
eternal and we know that an eternal
movie is coming to the MCU and Thanos is
an eternal himself so there are a lot of
connections here that tie back to
Chronos and since Thanos has basically
messed with the balance of the universe
and the Avengers are going to use time
travel there's a good chance that
Chronos might want to interfere a little
bit so these are the cosmic entities
that are linked to the MCU in some way
and these are new threats that could
come into play in Avengers in game but
also not take the main villain role away
from Thanos because they could appear
but they could also appear and let the
Avengers handle the situation and wait
to see how it plays out and at the end
of the day if the Avengers end up
defeating Thanos and undoing the snap
they just go away but we know that phase
4 of the MCU is going into the cosmos so
this would be a really good way to do an
actual introduction to supreme cosmic
entities in the MCU so let me know what
you think about these three cosmic
entities possibly showing up in Avengers
in game and now it's time for the
giveaway winner a lot of you have been
asking me how I choose the person that
wins the giveaway it is completely at
random and I will show you exactly how I
do it so the video that started the new
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway was Phoenix
force is the mind stone video so from
there I have done 38 videos I then go to
a random number generator on Google it
chooses a number and that is the number
of which video I choose then from there
I check how many number of comments
there are then I put that number into
the generator and whoever was that
numbers comment wins the giveaway so
congrats to Dustin gates for being the
next winner of the Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway shoot me an email and we'll get
you your Infinity Gauntlet for the rest
of you I'll be doing a new giveaway very
soon so stay tuned if you're new be sure
to subscribe to my channel so you can
stay up to date on all the Marvel
related news and Avengers and game and
as always thank you all so much for
watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you
[Music]